hello everyone and welcome to math
simplified i hope all of you are healthy
and happy
today we are going to take a close look
at a special vitamin that is essential
for our skin hair and nails vitamins are
substances that our body needs to grow
and develop normally
most vitamins need to come from food
because the body either does not produce
them or produces very little amounts
different vitamins play different roles
in the body and a person requires
adequate amount of each vitamin to stay
healthy
you may have heard about vitamin a b
vitamin c vitamin d and vitamin k but in
today's video we'll talk about a
forgotten vitamin vitamin h
yes you heard it right vitamin h
you may also know it by its common name
biotin or vitamin b7
well i say biotin is a forgotten vitamin
because most of us don't even know what
it does for us and why it is important
so let's talk about biotin its history
its role in our body the deficiency of
biotin and what you should include in
your diet to increase biotin intake
before we begin we would like to thank
you for your support if you like our
content subscribe to our channel it
helps us grow and make better content
for you
you can also find us on instagram we
post daily facts medical tidbits and
posts that will brighten your day the
links are in the description below
in 1916 scientist w g bateman observed
that a diet high in raw egg whites
caused a toxic disease in dogs cats
rabbits and even humans this was
confirmed in 1927 when researchers
observed that rats who were fed on an
exclusive egg white diet showed symptoms
of brain dysfunction hair loss skin
problems and eventually they died
but it wasn't until 1936 when some
german biochemists isolated the
crystalline substance from boiled egg
yolks they named it biotin because they
believed it was one of the components of
the bios
bios word which means life
biotin is a water soluble vitamin as you
might know our body can store only fat
soluble vitamins such as vitamin a
vitamin d vitamin e and vitamin k
hence biotin needs to be replaced by a
healthy and prudent diet
biotin is also known as vitamin b7 and
also as vitamin h
you might be wondering why vitamin h
well the h stands for har and hot
heart and heart are german words which
means hair and skin
so let's look at few of the important
roles of biotin in our body
number one biotin is an important part
of metabolic pathways
the food we eat goes through a lengthy
process involving various metabolic
pathways which eventually allow the body
to use it as energy
let me simplify this for you take for
example we take a healthy meal
containing adequate carbs good amount of
proteins and fat
once the food reaches our gut various
enzymes start acting on them these
enzymes break the larger macronutrients
into smaller micronutrients
once these nutrients are broken down
into small enough units they are
absorbed into the blood and sent all
over the body for utilization
it is here that biotin plays an
important role such as in
gluconeogenesis
which is a process where new glucose
molecules are synthesized from other
non-carbohydrate sources
while i won't go into the depth of the
gluconeogenesis pathway you just need to
know that biotin containing enzymes are
essential for gluconeogenesis
biotin is also important for amino acid
breakdown amino acids are the smallest
units that make up a protein
amino acids such as leucine require
biotin containing enzymes to be properly
metabolized in the body and to be used
biotin is also important for the
synthesis of fatty acids pads are the
primary way by which our body stores
extra energy to be used later biotin
dependent enzymes are vital for this
process of synthesizing fatty acids
the second important role of biotin in
our body is that it helps in maintaining
the health of our skin
hair and nails
keratin is a basic protein that makes up
your hair skin and nails
biotin improves the keratin biostructure
and eventually helps in maintaining the
hair and nail health
to study whether biotin is useful in
hair growth a 2015 study was done
over three months adult women who
reported thinning of hair were taken as
subjects 30 women were given oral biotin
rich marine protein supplements and 30
women were given placebos the scalp was
photographed digitally before starting
the supplements and the images were
compared to the scalp images taken 90
days later of the same areas
the results reported that biotin treated
subjects achieved a significant increase
in the number of hairs within the target
area biotin use also resulted in
significantly less hair shedding there
were no reported adverse events and the
researchers concluded that biotin
promotes hair growth and decreases hair
loss in women suffering from thinning
and loss of hair
number three
biotin is important in pregnancy
according to research a mild biotin
deficiency is common in pregnancy even
though the diets of most people are
biotin adequate it is reported that over
50 percent of all pregnant females in
u.s are marginally biotin deficient
this occurs because the vitamin is
broken down faster as a result a
pregnant female may require more biotin
than normal
number four biotin reduces blood sugar
levels
biotin is important in the metabolic
process of energy its deficiency can
negatively affect the glucose balance of
the body
in case of type 2 diabetes the body has
excessive blood sugar levels mostly due
to dysfunction in action of insulin
hormone
researchers say that a biotin deficiency
disrupts glucose regulation which can
have catastrophic effects for people who
are already struggling to control blood
sugar levels
researchers indicate that a combination
of biotin and chromium improves blood
sugar control in some people with type 2
diabetes the problem is that biotin
alone doesn't seem to have the same
effect and more research is needed to
determine whether supplementing biotin
can actually treat diabetes
now that we know some roles of biotin in
our body let's talk about biotin
deficiency and let's talk about what are
the symptoms of biotin deficiency
it is rare to become biotin deficient as
it is adequately present in most diets
but there are some special cases worth
mentioning this vitamin is especially
needed for gym and fitness enthusiasts
well people who eat raw egg whites are
especially at risk of developing biotin
deficiency this is due to a binding
factor called avidin which binds to
biotin and prevents the gut from
absorbing it
also people who have gut disease or who
are on parental intravenous feeding are
also at risk
some people who are on anti-seizure
medications and long-term antibiotics
are also at the risk of becoming biotin
deficient some of the symptoms of biotin
deficiency include hair loss dry scaly
skin tracks at the corners of the mouth
swollen or magenta colored tongue dry
eyes loss of appetite fatigue and
insomnia
depression
thinning and splitting of hair
brittle nails
glucose dysfunction
and nerve disease leading to numbness
and tingling sensations in hands feet
and legs
now that we know about the symptoms of
biotin deficiency let's talk about how
much biotin do you need daily
one way we measure a particular vitamins
or minerals requirement is by its
recommended daily intake
rda or recommended daily allowance is a
standard dose which is based on a
person's age sex and health status
according to the national institute of
health the daily requirement of biotin
is as follows
in infants biotin requirement is about 5
to 6 micrograms
children who are less than 12 years of
age require 10 to 20 micrograms of
biotin in their diet
teens required 25 micrograms of biotin
in their diet while adults require 30
micrograms in their diet
pregnant and breast feeding females
require a little more like about 30 to
35 micrograms of biotin in their diet
now let me tell you about a few foods to
boost your biotin levels
meats especially kidney and liver meats
are abundant sources of biotin
egg yolk also contains great amounts of
biotin
other sources include cheese soybeans
and peanuts
green leafy vegetables also contain good
amounts of biotin
other sources include cauliflower
mushrooms yeasts nuts and bananas
the bacteria in your gut also produce
minute quantities of biotin which is
then absorbed in your blood
heat can reduce biotin's efficacy so opt
for raw or minimally processed tissues
high dose biotin is being used as a
treatment for multiple sclerosis
multiple sclerosis or ms is an
autoimmune disease of the brain spinal
cord and nerve
this is because it damages the
protective functional covering of nerves
themselves
this covering is known as myelin
biotin is supposed to play an important
role in the production of myelin it
controls the key enzyme responsible for
myelin synthesis
so researchers are currently studying
the role of around 300 milligram per day
biotin
in treatment of multiple sclerosis that
is around 10 000 times the recommended
daily intake
the clinical trial results are mixed a
2019 review concluded that a further
investigation of the association between
multiple sclerosis symptoms and biotin
should be undertaken biotin holds a
great future prospect of treating this
serious disease
if you feel that your diet is lacking in
biotin or you just want to supplement
your biotin levels you can choose over
the counter biotin supplements also
these are very famous for their hair
benefits
i will link a few good biotin
supplements in the description box down
below so you can check them out
so friends this was all about this video
i hope you liked this video and make
sure to subscribe to our channel for our
upcoming videos thank you so much and
i'll see you in the next one